the Evil Dead franchise is back and with
no shortage of maggots from an elevator
of blood to a horrifying scene that will
make you think twice about using a
cheese grater these are some of the most
skin crawling moments in Evil Dead rise
warning spoilers ahead
in a change of scenery for the Evil Dead
series we leave the cabin in the woods
behind in favor of a rundown La
apartment occupied by Ellie for three
kids Danny Bridget and Cassie and her
sister Beth the film Ends by coming full
circle revealing what led to the film's
horrific opening sequence
in the closing scene we're shown the
morning after the Anarchy with the
apartment complex finally in a state of
calm it's then that we see that Jessica
the possessed girl from the opening once
lived in the same apartment as Ellie and
her family we quickly learned that she
slept through the earthquake and
subsequent Mayhem of the night before
completely oblivious to the nightmare
that's heard as she heads into the
parking garage she facetimes with
Theresa however as Jessica prepares to
leave the garage she notices the
aftermath of the previous night this
includes several puddles of blood and
Ellie's wrecked car just as she starts
to freak out she's swarmed on both sides
by more deadite spirits
following a powerful earthquake the
three siblings stumble across a hole in
the parking garage Danny descends into
it and finds a decrepit bank vault after
a fake out jump scare courtesy of a
Jesus statue Danny stumbles across a
payload of old documents and vinyl
records it's then that he finds an altar
of sorts adorned with a surplus of
crosses and crucifixes that contains the
Book of the Dead the trio returned to
the apartment where Danny and Bridget
begin examining the book hoping that it
might be worth some money the book's
pages are locked with sharp teeth and
Sinister veins are warming across the
cover it's those very sharp teeth that
Nick Danny causing his blood to drip
onto the book where it is quickly
absorbed into the cover the book's teeth
then unlock revealing Pages upon pages
of images depicting possession evil
rituals and horrific human sacrifices
following Ellie's possession she makes
several attempts on the lives of her
three children and her sister Beth her
oldest daughter Bridget is the first one
to be seriously wounded by her demonic
mom Mommy's with the man gets down after
stabbing Beth through the hand with a
piece of glass Ellie sets her sights on
Bridget and picks a unique weapon her
tattoo gun a demonic Ellie attacks her
daughter with the gun she stabs Bridget
in the cheek leaving a nice juicy cut
that she immediately hones in on Ellie
then extends her gnarled bloody tongue
and licks her daughter's wound infecting
her with dead-eyed blood leading to
Bridget's possession
early on in Evil Dead rise we see Cassie
making her staff that's half doll which
she names staphy when Ellie asks where
the scissors are the film makes sure to
show us that Cassie stashes them under
the couch this pays off later when Ellie
makes her way back into the apartment
through the air ducts once inside Ellie
immediately tries to murder Beth however
just as Ellie has Beth right where she
wants her a resourceful Cassie notices
the scissors and slides them to her aunt
Beth then takes the scissors and jams
them up into Ellie's face temporarily
incapacitating her and allowing her to
escape Evil Dead rise definitely
understands its fan base and wastes very
little time giving the people exactly
what they came for the movie opens in
familiar territory with a frantic POV
shot barreling through the forest before
soaring over a majestic Lake just as the
POV reaches Teresa a girl reading on the
dock it's revealed that this was nothing
but a clever fake out the POV we've seen
isn't a demonic Presence at all it's the
view from a camera mounted on a drone
the Drone is controlled by a guy named
Caleb he annoys Teresa a friend of his
girlfriend Jessica who is currently
resting up inside the cabin Theresa goes
back inside to read in peace and to
check up on her friend however as she
reads her book a strange sounding
Jessica begins reciting the words from
the book aloud as if she's reading
Teresa's mind as Teresa leans in to
check on her Jessica grabs her friend
and rips her scalp clean off her head
Teresa bleeding to death stumbles
outside and horrifies Caleb Jessica
follows and drags Caleb under the water
where she decapitates him with his drone
Jessica then rises from below the
surface as the film's title rises from
behind her
following Ellie's demonic first episode
Beth and the kids attempt to flee making
it into the hallway before Ellie gives
Chase it's here that Ellie reveals her
possessed form to the rest of the
floor's tenants and goes on a rampage
this includes jumping on her neighbor
Gabe and violently biting his face
eventually ripping his eyeball out with
her teeth in almost an instant Ellie
makes quick work of Gabe by ripping his
throat out as well as tearing his two
kids apart she also takes out an elderly
tenant randishing a shotgun it's a
brutal moment that shows just how
quickly Ellie can kill during The
Psychotic attack Beth and the three kids
get back inside the apartment and
barricade the door with the door
temporarily secured Beth approaches the
people and takes a look back out into
the hallway outside
the film truly kicks off when Dany plays
both of the vinyl records he's found in
the abandoned bank vault both records
contain recordings belonging to someone
associated with a church who has
translated The Book of the Dead the
words are spoken via the recording
immediately unleashing the deadite curse
on the apartment complex it's here that
poor Ellie while heading into the
parking garage is blasted back into the
elevator by some unseen entity as if the
wind wasn't thoroughly knocked out of
her already the elevator then Rockets
back up to the 13th floor after having
one of her piercings forcibly ripped out
by the invisible entity the elevator
itself begins attacking her a battered
Ellie heads back into the apartment
where in a possessed trance she begins
aggressively cooking eggs on the stove
what's up sis after a few back-to-back
incidents in the apartment Beth and
Cassie make a break for the hallway
still littered with the corpses of their
neighbors they try to enter an apartment
that has access to a potential getaway
route via the fire escape Beth grabs a
shotgun from one of the Dead residents
which she plans to use to open the
apartment but is distracted by Ellie
Beth shoots her demonic sister's leg
clean off her body but at this point
it's revealed that the rest of the
apartment residents are deadites as well
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for me
from Danny's elevator Vision in The
Shining to a recent sequence in Megan
elevators are definitely the last place
you want to be in a horror film case in
point the sickening fate that nearly
befalls Beth and Cassie when fleeing
from the hallway of Horrors after
skewering Ellie in the face with
scissors Beth and Cassie Escape out into
the hallway everybody here dies by Dawn
bad however as they look to unlock the
door of a potential Escape Route the
dead residents suddenly spring back to
life all under the influence of the
deadites as the possessed residents
taunt them with a chant of dead by Dawn
Beth and Cassie flee to the
malfunctioning elevator Cassie discovers
that what's been keeping the door jammed
are Ellie's keys from earlier allowing
the doors to finally close sadly after
hitting the button for the garage on the
lower level the elevator begins to fill
with gallons of blood the top of the
elevator is attacked by a dead-eyed
monster causing it to plummet to the
floor below this leads to a glorious
explosion of blood as the elevator
collides with the ground floor freeing
Beth and Cassie in the process
after being attacked by Ellie with a
tattoo gun Bridget heads into the
bathroom to examine her cut which looks
noticeably infected as she examines the
wound black veins begin spreading from
the cut followed up by a blood Fountain
pouring out of her nose and mouth not
long after her fate is clear when Beth
sees Bridget perched on the kitchen
counter with her back facing them when
she turns around Bridget reveals that
she is eating a glass vase leading to
some gnarly shots of the glass cutting
her throat from the inside she then
follows up the sick visual with another
one when she begins slicing up Beth's
leg with a cheese grater Cassie is then
forced to use staphney when she shoves
it through the head of her possessed
sister
after Beth and Cassie enter the elevator
of blood we see the possessed Danny and
Bridget shoving their arms inside Ellie
it's not clear why they're doing this
until we see a page from The Book of the
Dead the page shows a disgusting demonic
Abomination complete with several heads
and arms it explains the multiple sets
of arms frantically reaching into the
elevator to grab Beth and Cassie before
it crashes down into the parking garage
upon arrival in the garage the duo make
a beeline to Ellie's car desperately
trying to escape this nightmare
unfortunately the car gets stuck just as
the deadite monster enters the garage it
forces them to abandon the car and make
a break for the closing door on foot
just as they make it through the
creature snatches up Cassie and drags
her back into the garage as she gets a
good look at the creature Cassie sees
that it's a grotesque Fusion of Ellie
Danny and Bridget every Evil Dead movie
seems to go completely berserk in its
final moments and this this entry is no
exception after the reveal of Ellie's
demonic fusion with her kids Cassie is
completely at their Mercy even being
threatened with a chainsaw but Beth
rescues Cassie from the monster before
grabbing the chainsaw herself the
victory is short-lived though as Beth
trips and falls to the ground things
look dire for Beth as the maniacal
monster that used to be her family
decides to stuff her into a wood chipper
thankfully it's Cassie's turn to rescue
Beth as she manages to switch off the
chipper before her aunt is turned into
mulch Beth recovers the chainsaw and
begins graphically slicing up her
possessed family like meat in a deli
slicer she then forces the chunks
through the grinder one by one until all
that's left is Ellie seeing that the end
is near Ellie attempts to prey on Beth's
emotions once again by assuming a human
form however Beth isn't fooled and
shoves the chainsaw through Ellie's head
after the massacre in the hallway Cassie
and Beth barricade themselves in the
apartment it's at this point that Ellie
begins to sing a creepy song Cassie
climbs up on the dresser and looks
through the peephole almost as if she
can smell her Ellie immediately turns to
the door and begins talking to Cassie
telling her daughter that she feels
better and that it's safe to let her
back into the apartment Cassie's
skeptical of the claims simply says
it looks so good mom however Cassie
still Falls victim to the deadite Mind
Games and begins to unlock the door as
soon as Cassie opens the deadbolt Ellie
reaches through the door and grabs her
fortunately Beth grabs Cassie and pulls
her to safety
[Music]